deutschland ist in der krise und der
krieg treibt die preise hoch robert
habeck findet weniger duschen weniger
hände waschen und früher das licht
ausschalten energie sparen sollen wer
aber was ist eigentlich mit den
volksvertretern selbst sparen die dann
auch energie also sagen wir mehr ist
gelingt jedem haushalt oder die
allermeisten zehn prozent energie zu
sparen und das mal 40 millionen dann
macht es einen unterschied wir sollen
also alle energie sparen aber halten
sich die volksvertreter auch selber
daran licht heizung klimaanlage bild
macht den job der deutsche bundestag
sitzt unserer gewählten volksvertreter
hier werden gesetze gemacht aber im
sommer sind die meisten abgeordneten
nicht teil besuchen stattdessen ihre
wahlkreise draußen sind viele touristen
aber drinnen praktisch keine wir haben
sie gefragt sollte hier energie gespart
werden im moment ist der energiekrise
und co und wenn es nicht unbedingt sein
sollte dann musste auch energie gespart
werden gerade wenn von oben kommen der
kelter du schon so ein blödsinn ist halt
muss man sich selber anpassen also ist
klar verändert sitzung also müssen die
dinge an sein aber jetzt halt nicht
würden wir müssen sparen müssen noch
sparen wir waren hier sind die gerade
lang gegangen und haben die ganzen
großen suvs und fahrzeuge gesehen also
das würde ich auch mal eine
sparmassnahme solche wagen muss man sich
erst mal leisten können und ob de dort
wirklich so energiesparend sind das kann
ich eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen wenn
hier keiner ist müssen wirklich beide
fahrstühle im einsatz sein und müssen
wirklich alle lichter an sein
die frage ist für wen ist dieses
laufband an thema klimaanlage der fdp
politiker max motors ist einer der
wenigen übrig gebliebenen die hier noch
sind in seinem büro ist die klimaanlage
nicht an wie findet er dass moment sind
wir mit der stromversorgung sicher und
ich glaube 26 bis 28 grad ist schon
relativ viel in meinem büro wenn hier
die sonne rein knallt dann geht es auch
gut ab also ob das so arbeitsschutzrecht
ich noch in ordnung das weiß ich nicht
insofern ein bisschen kühlung ist auch
notwendig vor allem im anzug ein
politiker also der sagt energiesparen
hin oder her ich will eine klimaanlage
ansonsten ist die temperatur im ganzen
haus schön gekühlt zb hier auf der
fraktionsebene wie ist die temperatur
fragen wir
man sieht also hier sind nicht viele
leute trotzdem sind alle lichter an und
die klimaanlage läuft eigentlich auch
überall ob das energiesparen ist man
weiß es nicht